police were formed in the United States
Sheriff Kevin mcmahill says he wants
Metro to lead the way yeah he says by
changing how they approach everyday
duties the department can work to create
a more positive influence Victoria Saha
with a closer look at his plan
the way police officers interact with
the public has been a heavily debated
topic around the country but Sheriff
Kevin mcmahill says he wants his Metro
officers to set an example by serving
our community with Humanity cops matter
civilian members of this organization
matter a packed house with officers
hearing their Sheriff's vision for Metro
Police Department we have a great Police
Department
but we still have problems
problem and I want to make it even
greater if we really begin to inject
Humanity in that perspective we will
take this police work personal the
deaths of George Floyd and most recently
Terry Nichols have caused a huge
division when it comes to police
brutality and police reform Sheriff
mcmahill making it clear he does not
want Metro to be involved in similar
situations if we don't have Humanity in
our hearts as police officers and
Humanity in our hearts As Leaders to
make sure that we continue that effort
we're going to find ourselves in the
same place Sheriff mcmahill also says he
wants officers to respond to
neighborhoods that are crime ridden with
a new approach we're going to start
looking at him as vulnerable communities
Steve grandmas is the president of the
Las Vegas Police protective Association
he tells us his thoughts in the
sheriff's new approach I think his his
position was we got to stop calling them
bad neighborhoods and go after those bad
occupants in the neighborhoods
right now there are 300 open positions
at Metro Police Mick Mahal says the
graduation of an upcoming Academy should
cut that nearly in half even with that
there is a 70 percent drop in the number
of people applying
Sheriff mcmahal also touting a variety
of other items this morning he included
being more efficient at treating mental
health addiction and homelessness by
means other than incarceration and he
also mentioned a change will be coming
to officers uniforms